Four,
three,
two,
one.
And we're live.
How are you chuck?
I am great.
Look at this place.
Thanks for being here,
man.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
I've read your books.
I've,
I've watched movies based on your book,
so it's very cool to meet you in real
life and it's always a disappointment.
It is always so heartbreaking because
people expect somebody,
uh,
somebody,
so not me.
And I'm constantly breaking their heart
when they meet me.
Well,
I expect you so you're not breaking my
heart at all.
I'm very pleased to meet you.
So I didn't have any Weirdo expectations
or any delusions of who you are and
don't just,
just,
just don't,
don't kill yourself.
Okay.
I mean,
Anthony Bordain and he kills himself.
Well,
I think there was a lot of other factors
involved there.
I'm not,
I don't know.
I see this so many of my peers is like
that at the moment.
I meet them.
Boom,
they're gone.
Um,
yeah.
I'm,
I'm not gonna do that.
Okay.
So don't worry.
Everything's fine.
Um,
listen,
I want to talk to you about a bunch of
things.
First of all,
uh,
I would love to talk to you about your
writing process because one of the,
one of the things that I've read once
is,
uh,
I believe you were writing down,
it was on the Cape,
is in Massachusetts.
We ever writing down there,
we have a writing somewhere where you
made a deal with yourself where you
wouldn't turn the heat on unless you
were writing.
Oh my gosh.
Do you think I'm a white person?
Don't you feel weird?
The Cape,
the Cape?
He never been to the Cape Cod.
That's like an angel white people that's
in England,
New England,
New England.
Yes.
No,
I never read anything like that about
you.
No,
I'm sorry.
Never been on the Cape.
He never been to Cape Cod.
Never had a person.
She seems wonderful.
What's wrong?
A class?
No,
no,
no.
It's just something.
Maybe it's something that I attributed
to for many,
many years,
but it's just an interesting story that
someone said that they were forcing
themselves to be disciplined writing and
so they wouldn't,
right.
Unless they have the heat on.
And so they,
they lived in this place,
uh,
over the winter.
God wasn't you,
you were talking about Michael
Cunningham.
Is that who was yeah,
because he uh,
yeah,
I think that's his story about living in
province town.
Might've been fuck this all up,
but terrible way to get going.
I'm the one thing I wanted to talk to
you though being much lately.
No,
I don't any at all.
I just sleep.
I'm fortunate in that regard.
All right.
You don't take that shit to you?
Of course I do.
Do you?
Yeah,
three times a day.
Uh,
you're fucking with me.
We've got it.
We got started off poorly with me once a
day.
Do you really take ambien?
Yeah.
You know what,
to tell the truth just before I want to
do anything I don't want to do.
It's like a sh elves in the shoemaker
thing is I don't want to do my taxes.
So I take ambien and then I wake up and
my taxes are done.
Ah,
and do you have plausible deniability
too?
If you can get videotape,
you take an ambien.
People have committed murder on ambien
and gotten off because they had no
memory.
That is true.
Yeah,
it's a hypnotic,
we actually did a pretty in depth
discussion about that after the Roseanne
Barr thing came out.
My own mom,
uh,
has taken and she stopped taking it,
but one of the reasons why I stopped
taking it because she woke up in the
middle of the night and uh,
she had a white bathroom mat and she
painted it with lipstick and makeup.
She had no recollection of it
whatsoever,
but she painted it like a two year old
would.
They got ahold of their mom's lipstick
and she just woke up and what the fuck
am I doing?
Like what is this?
Hey,
she got off easy.
I've heard worse stories.
100 war stories.
Oh yeah,
no,
I,
I have heard about murder.
I've heard about people driving their
car to someone's house,
killing them,
driving home and having no recollection
of it.
A young woman in London,
climbed at the top of a construction
crane,
fell asleep on the huge counterweight so
far up over London,
wakes up in the morning,
birds around her.
She has no idea where she's at.
She is terrified.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
You writing about Ambien right now?
I am.
I can tell you locked in ambient and a
hundred other other things.
So if it's fair to say you,
it seems like you're writing like one of
the,
you're one of the ways you collect data
is almost like you're reporting on these
people.
Like you're,
you're collecting real life interactions
between people in real life
characteristics and then you incorporate
them into fiction.
Exactly.
That's fair to say.
My degree is journalism.
I have no idea how to be with people.
So I need to introduce a topic and see
if it resonates and then get everybody's
take on these common experiences and
then pick the very best one.
So in a way,
basically what I'm doing is kind of a,
an ongoing field study that becomes
whatever my next book is.
When you wrote Fight Club,
you tapped into something that w it was
really fascinating for me.
Uh,
as someone who's been involved in
martial arts my whole life and I,
I'm kind of understood the Cathartic
release of violence,
but I never saw it articulated the way
you did and you made it entices
[inaudible] for a thinking person.
He made it like you would,
you did it,
you,
you sort of opened up these,
uh,
these doors of understanding for someone
who may be maybe had frustration or had
some pent up rage or had some,
some adjuncts that just was not going to
get out any other way.
And then you wrote about it and then
when you bro,
you reading what you wrote at bank made
you go,
yeah,
okay.
Oh,
all right.
Now it's like you,
you added an element to it that really
didn't exist before in pop culture.
It was really fascinating for me as a,
as someone who's what,
watching that whole thing unfurl and
watching people get like really
resonating with people,
watching people really getting excited
about your work.
It's like,
oh,
he hit some nerve that nobody really hit
before.
Right.
And it's not a nerve that gets hit very
much,
you know,
and it,
there's so many different aspects to it.
And what is just my classic thing is
that there are so few social model
novels or stories for men,
for women.
There are a s you know,
every season there's a new joy,
luck club and knew how to make an
American quilt a new traveling
sisterhood of the Yamaha.
Yeah.
Whatever.
Just all these different models in which
women can come together and talk about
their lives.
And if you're a man,
you've got either fight club or you have
the dead poets society.
And that is really it.
So we don't have a lot of narratives
that depict to men a role or a kind of
script of,
you know,
uh,
in which to come together and talk about
their,
their shed.
And another thing is,
uh,
Jordan Peterson back to Jordan Peterson.
He talks about that need for really
rough play.
And he talks about it a lot.
And a lot of my friends did.
They brag about how badly they're kids
hurt them all.
My Gosh,
my daughter came at me the other day.
I had no idea how strong she was.
She pulled my arm out of the socket and
they're proud.
They're proud that their kid can play
that rough in his growing up that
strong.
But you know,
we've kind of fallen away from this idea
of consensual,
rough play.
And I think fight club resonated with
that a lot.
And also the idea of Joseph Campbell's
idea that there needs to be a secondary
father in men's lives that you're born,
if you're lucky with a biological father
that you do not choose.
And that is the,
the nurturing,
loving father that you eventually kind
of have to reject.
But in doing so,
you have to choose a new father and that
that father by choice typically is a,
a minister or a teacher or a drill
sergeant or a coach,
one of those fathers.
And you kind of put yourself in
apprenticeship to the secondary father
and you have to sort of consign your
life to the secondary father and agree
to learn what they're going to teach
you,
just like in karate kid.
And that is getting harder and harder
and harder to find.
So fight club was also depicting a new
form of the secondary father with all
these,
these kids that were showing up on the
doorstep of this ramshackle old house.
So there was just so many aspects of
men's lives that were not being
addressed when fight club came out and
it sort of reinvented so many of those
things that had fallen by the wayside.
That's a huge part of martial arts.
A huge part of martial arts is your
relationship with the master,
with the coach,
with finding someone who can guide you
through the,
the most dangerous waters,
uh,
of competition that it's,
it's absolutely imperative that bad
relationships with coaches are
absolutely disastrous.
And it,
it's,
it's imperative that someone find the
right coach,
find someone who they really can trust
and appreciate and you do develop.
It's a such a common theme.
They talk about this person being like a
son or this person being like a father.
You know,
I mean it's,
um,
it's,
uh,
I,
I never thought about it that way.
I forgot about that part of Joseph
Campbell.
But yeah,
that,
that is a huge,
huge issue with,
with young men and young men getting
into martial arts is something that I've
talked about so many times.
I don't discuss it as the need for rough
play.
I say that human reward systems that are
just not being,
did not being met,
and that systems that have been in place
for thousands and thousands of years
that are designed to reward us for
fighting off the enemy,
running away from danger or developing
physical skills and having a body that's
capable of,
of not just a physical activity but
violence.
Well and beyond just that,
you know,
it's also the whole idea of
apprenticeship in a,
whether you're apprenticing yourself to
a fighting coach or to a metallurgist or
to a welder or to a brick layer or to a
mason,
you are apprenticing yourself to
somebody that you're going to do all
this grunt work for.
But in exchange you're going to,
you're going to learn that kind of
really master skill at something.
Um,
and so it's a way of mastering yourself
as you mastered this other thing.
So you know,
it,
it's not just always a physical,
you know,
fighting thing.
It doesn't have to be in that form,
just difficult.
Something that's a struggle,
something that's hard to learn.
Right?
Yeah.
And that relationship that you have with
that secondary father to the,
it's almost in some ways more intense.
The,
the,
the pride of someone teaching you
something and then you eventually
developing those skills and then this
person who is teaching you this being
proud of your work is extremely
satisfactory.
Well,
and do you remember officer and a
gentleman?
Yeah.
You know,
Richard Gere really has this drunken dis
not their dad and then he has this drill
sergeant who's constantly trying to wash
them out and then finally he reaches it
at the existential crisis of saying,
you can't throw me out of the service
because I have no nothing else.
I have nowhere else to go in the world.
My life will amount to nothing unless I
can master this thing.
And he said,
relatively young man.
But it is that existentialist stick
moment where you,
you realize that you have to sacrifice
your youth for something.
You're not going to live forever.
It's a very martin heidegger moment
where you realize you have to become a
being,
living towards death.
You're not going to live forever and
you've got to give your life to
something.
Now,
when you
approach a novel like that,
when you have a story like that that's
brewing your head,
how do you decide what to pull the
trigger on?
Like do you just go on instinct?
Did you just have a,
a concept in your head and it just seems
more and more attractive and you just
say,
okay,
this is it.
You know,
one really good test is if you can take
it to a party and you can tell a very
small part of it,
as much of it as you know at that point.
And people will vie for a chance to
relate some aspect of their life that is
very much like that,
but an even more extreme example of
that.
So in a way they're there,
they're flushing out your theme with
parts of their own lives.
And so you find yourself drawing from
the experience of dozens or hundreds or
thousands of people,
and at the same time you're Beta testing
it.
You're kind of taking it on the road and
you're seeing that it's an idea that
resonates,
resonates with a huge number of people
that everyone can relate to it.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
So do you purposely let go to parties
with like a,
a couple bullets in the chamber
sometimes or sometimes they just go to
the party and I listened to hear
somebody tell that,
that personal anecdote that does evoke
all those other anecdotes because a
great anecdote doesn't leave people
speechless.
It leaves some competing to tell a
better version of the same thing.
And that's when a real writer to starts
realizing,
okay,
there's a pattern and that can be turned
into something really big.
That's really interesting.
There's a parallel there,
comedy for sure.
That's if you in good material,
oftentimes,
not always,
but oftentimes you'll see the audience
going,
Oh my God,
you do that or yeah,
that's fascinating.
Now,
um,
nothing I really wanted to talk to you
about is something that you brought up,
uh,
when you send the notes to Matt,
was um,
censorship and that and,
and,
and self censorship,
which is going on apparently.
And writer groups and groups of people
that are deciding that certain words
should be eliminated from vocabulary and
from vernacular and that you shouldn't
discuss certain things anymore.
These things are,
it's harming fiction and harming
literature.
Do you can't explore the darker ideas,
you know?
Oh,
you want to see me crucify myself right
now?
Yeah.
Okay.
This is kind of the,
uh,
career ending moment for,
for several years I was in a writer's
workshop and uh,
the core group of us had been meeting
since 1990.
So this is a workshop that was almost 30
years old.
And gradually people were asking each
other not to use certain words.
Uh,
first,
you know,
nobody really used the n word,
but it was definitely a word you could
not bring to workshop.
And then in a story,
I use the word faggot and a very good
friend of mine said,
you're not bringing that word into
workshop.
You're not writing anything with the F
word.
And,
and it just became more and more tightly
structured that way.
And so eventually I realized we were
kind of writing to make each other happy
instead of to kind of confront each
other.
And uh,
one of the writers in our workshop is a
writer named Cheryl strayed,
who,
who had written a book called wild,
which was a hugely successful book.
It was chosen as an oprah book and it
will be on bookstore shelves for the
rest of history.
Sheryl's book,
wild.
But while she was writing it,
she had written a segment about how as a
child she would be sat on the sofa with
her grandfather and her grandfather
taught her how to masturbate him.
And so as a child she would masturbate
her grandfather until he achieved
orgasm.
And then later she would find these
featherless featherless birds that had
fallen out of a nest.
And she picked one up and she knew it
would die.
So she crushed it between her bare
hands.
This is a very small child.
And she wrote how as that bird died
crushed between her hands,
it its death throes.
It's spasms of death felt exactly like
her grandfather's penis ejaculating in
her little hand.
Whoa.
That was the best thing she ever wrote.
And her editor,
Rick [inaudible] said,
that is not going in this book because
we want this book to be a big book.
And if we see you jerking off your
grandfather and then killing baby birds,
that is not going to make Oprah Winfrey
happy.
So it was a magnificent piece of writing
and a magnificent kind of parallel and
awareness for a child to have.
And this juxtaposition of sexual abuse
and death.
It was magnificent.
Oh my God,
it worked on every level.
But the publisher said,
this is not going to be in the book.
Did she send it to you or did she show
it to you?
She brought her to workshop and she read
it.
There was even a newspaper reporter pre,
uh,
present there and we all realized it was
fantastically powerful.
But then she said,
they won't take this.
This can't go in.
Wow.
Did she do anything with it?
So she published it online or no end.
There was so many parts of that book.
There was so much better than what they
actually did publish,
really.
And so it's that kind of censorship
where you're trying to reach a reader
standing in line at starbucks and this
has got to go in that point of purchase
stand and it's gotta be a face out.
And I understand for a long time,
if you wanted to face out yet a barnes
and noble,
especially on the discover new writers
face out stack,
you can not have the word fuck on the
first page because they did not want
people picking up that book and opening
it and seeing the f word that that just
did not fit their corporate culture.
And so,
you know,
so much of the censorship is,
is because people really want to reach
the largest audience without offending
people.
But there's giant problems with that.
Right?
I mean,
one of the more fascinating things about
books is that the story plays out in
your mind.
Exactly.
The nature of consumption makes it about
the only medium in which you can go to
those places.
Yeah.
Literally you,
you couldn't,
there's no way you'd be able to find,
to put that in a book,
Her story about her grandfather and the
bird.
Maybe you could put the burden,
but the grandfather par,
there's no snow way.
Yeah.
And I,
I,
I feel like I'm telling stories out of
school,
but it's such a perfect example of that
kind of self censorship.
Uh,
and it's also something so magnificent
that I feel is should come out.
It should sort of be stated.
Uh,
I don't want to steal her thunder.
I wanted to honor the story,
but it's like so many stories that
people tell me.
Uh,
I'm kind of seen as a safe person,
you know,
kind of a degraded monster maybe,
but as a degraded monster with no self
esteem whatsoever.
They feel safe telling me these things
because in a way they probably feel a
little morally superior to me.
Um,
why do you think people would consider
you a degraded monster?
Because I can read a story like guts
that is so completely humiliating
because as I read it,
it's in the first person.
So people more or less assume that it's
my story,
even though it's stories garnered from
many different people.
But the fact that I'm presenting it
means that I'm the person that is this
losing face and afterwards people feel
like they can risk losing face by
telling me their story.
That's very much like the gut story.
So when someone is writing something
that's deeply disturbing like that,
when you,
when you hit those parts of your mind
and you come to this pathway d,
do you consider,
do you say,
well no one's ever going to allow this
to be in a book.
No one's ever,
do you consider those thoughts or do you
just go through with it first and then
review it?
Or do you not do that at all?
You know,
my formative years with a punk,
heres the 70s into the 80s and we always
used to have a saying,
people would say,
ah,
don't hit the brake until you hear the
glass break or don't stop until you hear
glass break.
And so I always think the point of
writing is to coach yourself to that
point that you would never have gone
voluntarily.
And also to coach your reader to the
point where the reader would never have
gone voluntarily.
And a story like guts,
you know,
it's very funny on the front end and if
you told people on the front end where
it was going to go,
they'd never read that story.
But it's very funny and charming and
well paced on the front.
And then once people realize where it's
going to go,
they're already trapped.
And so in a way is,
it's a way to enjoy that though.
Like the way you said they're already
trapped.
You seem to take some satisfaction in
that.
But in writing it,
I'm also sort of springing the trap on
myself starting down a path that I have
no idea is going to be so humiliating or
so,
uh,
emotionally upsetting or so dark.
Because if,
if I did,
I would never go down that path.
When you write a story like that,
how much of a deep plan out in advance
I might plan out up to the end of the
second act.
You know,
at the moment of greatest crisis,
this will happen,
you know,
in fight club,
the moment of greatest crisis is going
to be when everyone in the support
groups figures out that this guy is
lying to them and they're all given the
choice of either accepting him for his
transgressions or rejecting him.
Same thing in choke.
There's going to be that moment.
And uh,
when people realize that he has faked
choking and that he's made them into a
fake hero and they're going to either
kill him or accept him.
And so I typically know that the second
act is going to end with a transgression
being revealed.
But beyond that,
I don't want to know because I want the
story to complete itself with its own
momentum at that point.
And if it doesn't surprise me beyond the
second act,
then it's not going to surprise the
reader.
Do you write,
do you have like a storyboard laid out
and do,
do you use like index cards or anything
to figure out where things are going or
do you just Kinda know now?
No,
you know,
that's part of the glory is that
whenever I get stuck,
I go to the gym and I say,
okay,
I'm working on this scene where this
happens and this happens and this
happens.
And my friends will say,
they'll always be somebody there with a
really fresh take and life experience
who can say,
well,
have you thought about this happening?
And it will take the story in a
direction that is so unexpected because
it's not from my experience and that
that's the glory.
And they feel like they've contributed
there.
They're so happy.
And uh,
and I'm happy to spend time among people
and I'm happy to have the story complete
in a way that I never,
ever could have anticipated.
That's fascinating.
So you do it at the gym.
Yeah,
the gym is really great because you're
around people and you have these
recoveries between sets.
So you have a little time to talk.
And at the same time you have,
during the exercise itself,
you have time to think.
And so it paces the talking versus a
thinking and it's also kind of highly
oxygenated and it's physically active.
And your mind is kind of mind is not
engaged with something else.
Your mind has kind of disengaged like it
is while you're taking a shower.
Yeah.
A lot of people like to walk.
They like to read a write,
read a little bit of it,
and then walk and bring a recorder or
their phone to record on think.
Probably along the same lines,
Charles Dickens walked somewhere between
12 and 20 miles a day as he wrote.
Whoa.
And the,
uh,
the lakeland poets walked constantly.
I mean,
walking is a big part of writing
anything physical,
right?
Like anything,
we,
you're forcing your body to move,
forcing the blood to flow and also
mindless so it allows your mind to
wander.
Yeah.
So I love the fact that you're so open
with these ideas too,
that you're,
you bring them to people and get their
take on it and then incorporate their
take.
Is this something you've always done
because of the workshopping?
Is it because it just is this
willingness to be open with your ideas
and express them?
Yeah.
Really in a workshop was the crucial
thing.
Having that social expectation that
you're going to bring work every week.
And it was also kind of a party,
a reward for having brought the work.
And it was also a way of testing the
work so that you knew whether it was
working,
you know,
you weren't constantly sort of
questioning yourself.
A workshop just provide so many really
important ways of uh,
keeping right,
keeping you writing now w e and you've
done this always.
They've seems like you've done this most
of your career.
I have,
and this is not the first workshop I've
been bumped out of.
The first workshop I was in was a very,
a lot of very nice ladies and I was
probably 28 and I had written a scene in
which,
uh,
a man,
a young man has done up an inflatable
sex doll.
So it looks exactly like the woman he's
obsessed with.
And during the,
the seduction of this sex doll,
he accidentally snags the back of it
with a zipper of its dress and he
realizes during the fornication that it
is gradually losing air.
So he's got to copulate faster and
faster to try to achieve orgasm before
this thing completely goes flat.
And at the end of the scene,
he's standing there with this completely
deflated sex doll hanging off of his
erection like this,
the surrender flag.
And of course,
his mother walks into the room.
And after I wrote that scene,
the leader of the workshop,
I was in my first workshop,
she took me aside afterwards and she
said,
uh,
the other writers in the workshop no
longer feel safe around you.
She really did.
She,
she said,
you've written something that really
frightens them,
uh,
and they would like you to politely
leave the workshop and not come back.
Wow.
And so that's when I started with,
uh,
Tom Spann bowers workshop in which
almost anything wet.
Um,
and so this kind of periodic implosion
of the workshop,
uh,
is kind of part of the process.
Well,
it seems only twice right?
Or more and more times than that.
You know,
it's been twice,
uh,
but in the past it's catastrophic.
Twice catastrophic.
Yeah.
But a few other flat tires along the
way.
Uh,
periodically we've kind of had to
pretend that we were disbanding in order
to get rid of a member who was a,
uh,
just more trouble than they were worth.
How many people are in these workshops?
Boy,
lately it's been last,
it was about eight,
but we've been up to like 16,
17.
And now when I teach,
I typically have about 25 people.
What does it feel,
I mean,
to be in a workshop for that long and
then have such a,
a disagreement and to disband like that
or to have you forced out,
what does that feel like?
That's got to suck.
No,
you know,
I think in a way we all need a kind of a
respite from each other.
We all had kind of knew what to expect
from one another and I think we were all
less,
less of a resource for one another.
Uh,
you know,
there's always a chance we'll come back
together.
So,
uh,
so it's not a big tragedy.
So there's a chance that they might,
so did they kick you out or did they
just disband?
I left the workshop and I understood
that it disbanded wreck after that.
The seams.
I just don't understand how someone who
is a creative writer can't understand
the,
the not just the necessity,
like the need to delve into the darker
possibilities of,
of human reality that this,
those stories she wrote about her
grandfather in the bird is a perfect
example of that.
I mean,
although very few people will experience
that in their life,
we all can appreciate that these are
possible scenarios.
And I think it,
it,
it really comes down to what people,
uh,
what purpose reading and writing serves
in people's lives.
And most people,
they want reading to be a comforting
activity.
They want to be able to read a book and
then fall asleep knowing the detective
will apprehend the killer by the end of
the book.
That things will end very well in a way
that you want to be bored or lulled by
the book.
Uh,
not so many people really want to be
kind of confronted by books,
but some people do.
Right?
I mean,
isn't it,
it's kind of like a pretty much all
forms of art.
Whether it's music or movies,
I mean there's superhero movies and then
there's movies like no country for old
men or the bad guy gets away at the end
and you'll,
you leave the movie theater and you're
like,
what the fuck?
You know?
But those,
those are all satisfying in different
ways to different people.
And isn't that sort of the point of
creative expression is that you're
getting surprised,
you're getting taken down a row that is,
here's the world through this person's
eyes and they create this world.
If you put limitations on that,
you're going to,
yeah,
you're going to eliminate some
disturbing aspects that my bother some
people.
But you're also gonna eliminate some
magical moments that might just carry,
might literally let,
might change the way you view people.
You know,
part of it has to do with the nature of,
you know,
movies,
movies are going to always kind of
attract,
uh,
a more dynamic audience.
Movies carry their own authority through
motion and books are going to be a
slower medium that's harder to consume.
And so maybe books are always going to,
at this point,
be seen of it as kind of a sedative as a
kind of thing that lulls you and
conference you and puts you to sleep.
But by who?
By some people,
right?
I mean,
maybe there's a market for those kinds
of books,
but there's also a market for your
books.
There's,
there's,
there's clearly a market for people that
they want to tap into those more
disturbing
backs of consciousness and reality.
And that market is moving to video games
and that market is moving to edgier
films.
There's just other forms of storytelling
that are serving that market better.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Better than books.
Yeah.
But why is that?
Is that because of the censorship or
it's because artists aren't exploring
those ideas as much anymore.
You know,
and part of it is because books are
harder to consume.
Books take an enormous amount of a
commitment of time and effort to read a
book where everything else is 30 minutes
to two hours and to write a book as well
mean,
such a solitary discipline to sit alone
with your computer.
No,
it is not,
not for me.
And I,
I hate that model.
You know,
I want to be in the mermaid tavern
talking about my ideas with my
compatriots and getting their take on
him and finding out how it resonates
with everything else in people's lives.
What's The mermaid tavern?
Oh,
is the,
the reference to where,
uh,
um,
not coleridge.
All the famous writers of Shakespeare's
time,
ah,
basically hung out at a,
it was like the white horse tavern in
New York,
but the mermaid tavern was in London
during that time.
Um,
and uh,
Boswell,
uh,
all the writers hung out there and
exchange ideas and entertained one
another.
Hmm.
And so I want writing to be my social
outlet,
but you have to write it by herself.
Right?
I mean when you're,
when you're sitting alone actually
putting your fingers on the keyboards.
No,
you,
you do that part in airplanes.
Really?
Yeah,
I've right.
Notebooks and notebooks and notebooks in
public.
And then when I'm trapped in some
unbearable place,
like an airplane or an airport,
then I do that horrible part of
keyboarding.
Yeah.
So that's the only time you actually
write,
right?
The keyboarding is not writing.
You remember the Truman Capote,
he quote about uh,
on the road,
Jack Kerouac Capote,
he said that's not writing.
That's typing and still the part on the
airplane or in the airport where you
have the laptop open.
That's not writing.
Really.
That's typing.
This is writing.
Writing to you is physical pen to paper.
Ah,
sloppy everything.
Yeah.
Why is that?
Why is it different?
Because it's written down in the moment
that you hear it.
And that is not set in new times.
Roman 12 point so that it looks so
finished.
It looks like a finished book and it's
much harder to monkey with it.
Once you see it on that screen.
And in word,
uh,
it looks like a book.
It's much harder to edit it,
but when it's scrawled on the page in
front of you,
you can draw arrows,
you can scribble it out,
you can,
you can do whatever you want to.
It is,
it's much less precious.
Is this something that you voted this,
the approach of Oh taken.
Did you learn this approach or is it
something that just sort of made sense
to you?
This is how old I am.
It used to be,
I grew up in the age of uh,
typewriters when even typewriters were
kind of precious because you would have
to buy ribbons for them.
And those ribbons were really expensive.
And so something had to be written out
completely.
Long hand had to be perfect longhand
before you could risk wasting a
typewriter ribbon to type it out.
Wow.
So you just developed it this way and
just stuck with it.
Even the age of computers.
Well,
and also because writing is something I
do in the moment,
somebody says something insightful,
something really bright,
something phrased just wrong so that
it's suddenly really fresh and I want to
be able to write it down in that moment.
So that when I do have to go to the
boring part with a keyboard,
I have got so much wonderful fresh stuff
that it makes a keyboarding part fun
because it allows me to sort of archive
and a cure rate,
preserve these fantastically bright
things that were said by so many
different people.
And you don't,
do you ever record,
do you ever record yourself like record
ideas then listened to them transcribe
them?
Oh God,
no,
no.
I hate that.
That was a big hunter s Thompson thing.
He would record a lot of his ideas and
then transcribe them and write them out.
You know,
I kinda write word for word sentence for
sentence.
And so,
uh,
the transcription is just too much of an
effort for me.
Usually when I do interviews for
magazines,
um,
I will record my interview subjects and
even then,
uh,
transcribing the interviews is so it's
such a misery because people seldom talk
in complete sentences and there's so
many false starts and so many sentences
that just don't go anywhere.
Right.
So no,
talking into a recorder is just that a
mess.
And so this notebook,
do you have in front of you this,
this is a notebook for life or is this a
notebook for particular project?
Like how do you,
how do you organize it?
This is a notebook where three pages are
devoted to topics that I will talk to
you about if we're desperate.
And uh,
they're a little notes in here about
contacting my agent for different
issues.
Also,
it's all universal.
It's like for all sorts of things,
for tasks that you need to do.
And then as well as that parts of books
you're writing.
And there's all these little notes that
Jamie just gave me about microphones.
Yeah.
You're writing something about someone
who's into recording equipment.
Yeah.
That's just a small part of it.
But that's what she knows.
And now this,
I want to go back to this workshop
thing.
Like what was it?
Just words,
just the,
the use of the word faggot or the n
word.
It was just words that characters were
utilizing in your story that was so
disturbing to them.
Yeah,
it was words,
but it was also some situations that I
thought were,
you know,
I got that people were very upset by
people would leave the room where people
would leave the room or what would weep,
uh,
would weep in just complete upset.
Does part of you go,
yeah,
I got this and you see someone weeping
some shit you wrote?
No,
most of the time people would go to the
bathroom and weep and I would find out
about it much later.
So I said,
did you get post satisfaction that way?
No.
It just made me feel like a bully and
that really kind of another thing that
is a thin line,
especially when I read a story like
guts,
am I entertaining people or am I
bullying them?
Am I beating them up and I also bullying
wine that way.
Why do you what?
Describe it that way.
Kind of charming them into a story that
eventually will make them faint.
Or eventually we'll,
we'll make them Rach,
but will upset them very deeply.
Uh,
and I,
I feel a real reluctance about that.
Doesn't that sort of have to bridge,
have to be crossed though if you're,
if you're really going to explore every
single possibility in a creative
narrative,
if you're,
if you're really gonna write a book and
just let your mind go wild,
that has to be on the table,
doesn't it?
It does.
But I don't think it hurts to be aware,
uh,
so that you don't lapse into being a
bully for the sake of being a bully.
You know,
I think anybody who has a really hard
trainer,
uh,
kind of,
you know,
comes up against that and my,
a really good trainer or as part of me,
a sadist,
and you have to make sure that you don't
become that sadist,
but so you're not a monster.
So there you go.
Yeah.
But I worry about it.
Well,
that's why you're not,
but it's the
being able to explore those
possibilities and being able to just
delve into the deep recesses of your
mind in the interest of creativity.
That seems to be,
if anybody's going to appreciate that
it's going to be creative writers,
but it's not my mind.
I'm delving into the deep recesses,
if I'm lucky,
if I'm doing it right,
your mind of something that they'll like
comedians and they'll say,
oh my gosh,
that happened to you too.
And a lot of times there are things that
people have never ever talked about.
Uh,
I tell a classic anecdote after I'd read
the,
uh,
the guts story at an event,
a woman came up and uh,
she was a middle aged woman.
She was about my age and she said,
I really loved that you read that story
about how you,
uh,
got your anus prolapsed while
masturbating and swimming pool,
which is not my story,
but I'm the one that read it.
So that's the one,
I'm the one that they're picturing in
this horrendous situation.
And she says,
since you can tell that story,
I'm going to tell you a story.
And she said,
how when,
when she was seven years old,
she was in second grade and she was in a
little organization called the brownies,
which is a precursor to the girl scouts.
You,
you wear a brown dress,
little brown hat,
you get these little merit badges.
And she said,
one day I had a stomachache and my mom
kept me home from school and we had this
heating pad,
it must've been in the 1960s and this
heating pad had this vibrating function
and she put me face down on this heating
pad on my stomach and I fell asleep and
while was asleep,
this vibrating warm heating pad must
have slid down between my legs.
She says,
because I woke up with the most amazing
feeling I feeling like I had never felt
before.
Oh my God,
it felt so good.
And so
next time it was my turn to host the
brownies.
I said Brownies because you've got to
try this heating pad.
And she says all the brownies,
they turn the heating pad on the
vibrating heating pad.
And they wrote it like a pony all
afternoon.
And she said it was like sex in the city
for seven year old girls.
They could not get enough of this
heating pad.
And they were all riding this heating
pad and they had a great time.
And she said,
and for the first time in my life I was
the most popular girl in my class and I
was the girl that all the girls wanted
to play with.
And for every Brownie troop meeting it
was at my house and I was the leader
until the day that my mother came home
from work early and she caught us with a
heating pad and she sent the other
brownies home and she whipped the cord
out of the wall.
She just ripped it out of the socket and
she started to beat me with it and she
beat me with that court and she beat me
and she said,
you fucking piece of shit.
You dirty whore.
What kind of a fucking whore am I
raising you?
Whore.
And she beat me,
she beat me.
And she says this woman who's my age
now,
she says,
I have not had an orgasm since I was
seven years old.
And then she goes,
but if you can tell that swimming pool
story about how you got hurt jacking off
underwater,
she says,
I can tell my heating pad story and I
can tell that story until I can make it
funny.
And then maybe somebody I can go back to
my mom and I can say,
do you remember that heating pad we used
to have and it'll be complete whole
shit.
And so cc cc,
that's what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to create the opening for
people to tell these stories that they,
they never thought that they could tell
because that's the way in which they're
going to resolve these stories and
they're going to master these stories.
We have these,
um,
but de toilette things that have a
little button on the wall,
you press it,
it shoots hot water up your ass.
And,
uh,
my kids come over and did love these
toilets.
I have two daughters and my youngest,
when she was seven,
she would sit on the toilet and she was
laughing and giggling and we didn't tell
her there's anything wrong with it.
So she was telling us how much she loves
it,
how much she loves the hot water when it
shoots onto her.
But she was like,
it feels so good.
And there was no shame in it.
And there was this weird moment where
I'm like,
am I supposed to react to this?
Am I supposed to say?
Yeah,
I know I like it too.
Am I supposed to say,
Hey,
don't do that too much.
Am I supposed to say don't tell anybody
you like that you can like it,
but don't tell anybody you like it.
Like what am I supposed to do?
And uh,
I didn't do anything.
I just let her smile and she walked out
of the bathroom laughing like it was
great and it was,
no,
there was no issue.
But it was this moment where I was like,
wow,
if I was a religious person or a
suppressive person or some person with
some sexual issues,
this could be a real problem for this
little girl.
Instead I was like,
okay,
let's get out of the bathroom now.
I guess you're done.
All righty.
And she has no idea that this was even
like a moment of crisis in my mind or I
was like,
okay,
how do I handle this?
I'm in the bathroom with my seven year
old daughter,
just can't water shot up her ass and
she's enjoying it.
So you talk about it on the radio,
is that how you deal with that?
Right.
Joy to share.
I enjoy too.
We all do.
We talk about these toilets.
They're amazing.
It's warm water.
Choosing your,
it's great.
It feels awesome,
but it's not supposed to feel awesome
for like a little girl for some reason.
Right?
See you tell that story and people will
have so many versions of that story.
For me,
I was in Germany.
I went in the bathroom in the airport.
I didn't know what this button was,
so I pressed it.
I looked down just in time to see this
little plastic arm swing out.
I didn't know what that thing was going
to do,
so I jumped off the head and this thing
shot up with such force.
It knocked a ceiling panel out of the
ceiling and all this hot toilet water
came sprinkling down on me.
Uh,
and I,
that's the only time I've ever been
around one of those.
While we have one here,
if you want to try it out,
I don't know.
It scares me.
There's two of them.
It's one in that bathroom,
one of that one,
one of that bathroom you could lock.
It's private.
And see that's my process is you can
tell these stories and you kind of
gathered the stories that people tell
related to these stories and you choose
the ones that escalate the fastest,
the escalate the best.
And that gives you a gradual sort of,
you've established the precedent and
then something worse,
escalating,
worse,
escalating to the most atrocious or
extreme version.
And that's what brings a story to crisis
is
I,
I have a hard time believing that
someone would be angry with that woman
for her story.
You know,
and it's not,
it's hard.
It's about her and her story,
her relationship to that story.
That one you're going to get away with.
You'll get away with that one.
The d jerking off the grandfather one is
in a different place.
She's because she's a victim of sexual
abuse.
She's a victim of VI.
It's strange that violence,
for some reason,
it's more acceptable than sexual abuse
and a lot of ways sexual abuse seems to
be transformative.
Like there's something about sexual
abuse that it,
it ruins you introduce a,
an experience,
a memory into a person's life that ruins
them.
This is the rough segue,
but I find with so many beginning
writers is that they have absolutely no
capacity to be with tension or suspense.
So they might start to create suspense,
but then they'll resolve it instantly.
And so the story never really gets off
the ground because something has
happened to them,
whether it's violent or whether it's
sexual abuse,
that that makes them cling to a kind of
calm serenity and that's all they want
and that's all they ever want.
And then writing in a way seems to be a
way of coaching them back to a greater
and greater tolerance with the
unresolved with,
with the,
the tense,
with suspense
is some of the best moments in books
that I've read are moments where you're
reading and you're like,
oh fuck.
Like where's this going?
Like,
you know,
you're going to get introduced into some
really disturbing scene
and you have to be with that.
You have to be with that until it's
resolved.
And that's good writing.
You know,
bad writing is where it comes up.
It's resolved.
Now when you're in this workshop and
they're discussing with you this
possibility of censorship of you sell,
censoring or have them not accepting
your ideas.
Like how do you,
how do you debate that with them?
How do you,
how do you talk about that?
Boy,
there's really no debate,
you know?
Ah,
and,
and that was another aspect,
aspect of the workshop is that we had
all known each other for so many years
that,
uh,
mmm,
they're really,
we didn't have the freedom to kind of
teach each other or anything new.
Um,
yeah.
So there was a staleness there too.
We were all kind of hardened into the
people we were going to be.
I just don't understand their argument.
I just don't understand.
If you're going to really paint a
monster,
you have to have monster's actions.
Yeah.
They have to be a real monster.
We know of real monsters.
I mean,
it was just some,
some guy just got arrested,
some had sex slaves in his basement.
And you know,
you hear about those people and you go,
yeah,
they're out there.
There's probably a hundred of them
scattered across the country right now
where they have a locked basement and we
don't know about it.
Those are real people.
But if you wrote about one of those
people using real scenes that were
depicted in the news,
you know,
real eyewitness testimony,
real interviews with these monsters,
some people would object to that.
But if you're gonna write about a
monster,
you have to write them in a monstrous
way.
Oh,
I,
I totally agree.
Um,
yeah.
What are they trying to achieve?
Like I just don't understand what,
okay.
They might not enjoy what you're doing.
They might not,
might not be something that they want to
take in recreationally,
that they want to read your work in that
in that way.
But the fact that they don't appreciate
what you're doing or the fact that they
don't want you to do what you're doing
and they didn't want you to bring it to
the workshop.
Is this a new thing?
This is,
is there a new trend?
You know,
it's,
in a way it's a,
it's an ongoing thing for me because,
you know,
I've been kicked out of workshops before
for just going a little bit too far.
Uh,
and uh,
so in a way it's kind of a,
it's maybe my goal.
Maybe my goal is to,
you know,
always piss off my Beta audience.
Um,
as a way of kind of proving that I've
gone too far.
Um,
yeah,
too far though,
it's too far.
When you piss off the Alphas,
well not the Betas,
right?
It's,
it's,
you go really far when you piss off
Psychos,
when they're like,
Jesus,
man,
the fuck you doing in my brain,
you know?
Oh God,
that's another thing not to talk about.
Just keep calling.
Oh my books were banned so many places
and uh,
and sometimes I think that maybe that's
a good thing because they don't,
aren't reaching the psychos.
My books are abandoned prison systems,
Watson,
because they are enormously popular.
These prison librarians tell me,
but the books are considered way too
stimulating.
So wow.
People in prison cannot read my books.
Oh Holy Shit.
All prisons,
I'm don't know if it's all but it's
Texas and a number of other really big
states.
So I dunno,
that's kind of a badge of honor.
Yeah.
But it doesn't equate to the like the
uh,
the mortality of being banned.
Like a how or a tropic of cancer or
Salman Rushdie.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Oh God.
That fucking struggle,
man.
The struggle of wanting to express
yourself as freely as possible,
but being limited even by your own
peers.
That is,
um,
that's unexpected to someone who's in
the outside of literature.
Someone who just reads it.
Cause it's not in the comedy world what
is in the comedy world,
but not amongst good comedians.
Well,
another aspect of that is that so often
people aren't censoring it because it
offends them.
They're censoring it because they're
afraid it will offend someone.
They know they're doing it.
They're kind of white knighting on
behalf of someone else.
David Sedaris told me this story about,
uh,
telling a joke,
or something very funny about a girl in
a wheelchair and how he looked out in
the audience and no one was laughing.
They were all looking at a girl in a
wheelchair.
And the moment she started to laugh,
the entire audience started to laugh.
Oh yeah.
And so,
so often people in the workshop,
they might not personally feel offended
by the word,
but they're thinking how that word might
hurt people.
They know.
But yeah,
that's a fact.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a giant issue in comedy.
If you,
if someone's telling you a joke of
someone's on stage talking about someone
who's fat and there's a fat person in
the front row,
that joke will bomb.
Yeah.
It just,
yeah.
But that's because people are good
people overall.
You know,
they recognize that they don't want to
cause pain.
Another really odd comic David Sedaris
story is that he always told me,
uh,
when you're on the road,
don't read from your current book.
Always read from the next book pieces.
So we have road testing the stories and
finding out which ones work and should
go into the next book.
And in doing so,
he was telling the story about being in
this,
uh,
this forensic,
laboratory isn't an,
as an autopsy was taking place and this
autopsy table was adjacent to dis this
huge indoor window that separated the
autopsy suite from this lunch room and
in the lunch room where the rest of the,
uh,
the forensic staff and they're all
eating their lunches.
They all had tuna sandwiches and cans of
coke and barbecue potato chips.
And they were watching through the
window as is absolutely perfect.
12 year old boy was being autopsied and
just hours before this kid,
like two hours before this kid had been
riding his bicycle,
he'd fallen over,
he'd hit his head on the curb and now
two hours later he was dead and dead
without almost a scratch on him.
Just this perfect naked,
dead 12 year old boy on the autopsy
table.
And as he,
the,
the technicians eating their lunch,
watching it through a window that they
watch as the,
uh,
as the,
pathologist in sizes around the top of
the kid's face at the top of the
forehead,
the hairline,
and then peels a face down like peeling
an orange peels the entire face off of
the skull of this little boy and leaves
the face around the neck like a mask,
like a rubber mask.
And this exposes this liver colored dark
red musculature of the child's
underlying face.
And this one guy watching it with a
mouthful of tuna sandwich,
he points this out and he says,
see that?
That there,
that's the color of red that I want to
paint our rec room.
Holy Shit.
And once the Darice told that story in
front of 600 people,
okay,
it was dead silent.
And you could hear people weeping.
Okay?
People were crying and they were hating
David Sedaris in that moment.
And so I had to laugh.
I laughed really loud like a donkey.
And it was amazing how that hatred in
that auditorium swung from hating David
who they did not want to hate to hating
this jackass over here who was actually
laughing.
And so I threw myself on the sword for
David and that story never went in any
book.
Wow.
Did the story Naco in any book just
because of the reaction by the audience
or just an uncomfortable moment?
He just decided he would speak to him
about it.
No,
I didn't.
Not afterwards.
It was just such an awkward,
painful thing.
I would never kind of throw it back in
his face.
Right.
To my knowledge,
that was the only time the story was
told to have those like scattered about
or there this,
are there scenes what you wrote and he
just sat and looked at him and went,
no,
I just got to put that one somewhere
else.
Oh,
there's that other side jokes that I
told where I got hist by 800 people.
And you know,
as you can live through those moments
when you realize you can live through a
lot,
if you can be hated by 1100 people at a
barnes and noble on Union Square.
Oh yeah.
You can be hated by your mother.
It's okay.
I know when those people come to see
you,
how many of those people are fans of
literature and how many of those people
are specifically fans of your work?
Like there's,
there would be a difference.
Like the,
the people were fans of your work would
at least expect some uncomfortable
moments.
And for the most part they tend to be
more or less just fans of my work and
still still his,
oh yeah.
But it's again,
they're hissing on behalf of someone
than I hissing up for themselves.
You know,
I made this horrible cheap shot and they
always knew a cheap shot.
People always know a cheap shot.
I,
uh,
I was commenting about how in breakfast
at tiffany's,
Truman capote had made this observation
that Americans don't like true beauty,
true classical natural beauty.
They want to see a very plain person who
has been so groomed.
So exercise,
so made up so style stylized that she
can kind of pass as this,
this amazing,
strange beauty.
That's what Americans want because
natural classic beauty is not
egalitarian.
You're either born with it or you're
not.
They want to see a plain person who has
been transformed.
And to make my point at the end of the
story,
I made a cheap shot.
I said,
and that's why we have Sarah Jessica
Parker and I said this in New York and
in New York,
Sarah Jessica Parker is worshipped like
a god and that whole crowd hissed and
booed and did everything but throw
excrement at me.
Wow.
But then later in line,
half of them came up and whispered.
That was really funny.
Yeah,
that's,
well that's one of the things about dark
comedy clubs.
You want them dark?
No,
you don't want everyone illuminated like
the,
when the,
the crowd is like the one,
this is one of the real issues with
doing a comedy special is that uh,
especially the old way they used to do
them and they still like to light up the
audience,
which completely changes the dynamic of
the,
the room changes,
what you'll laugh and what you won't
laugh at.
You know,
in a scene like this,
Erica,
Sarah Jessica Parker joke,
it's perfect example.
Like you don't want to be caught dead
being the one person that throws her
head back and how's it that
no cheap shots or just to stay away from
them.
But that's another,
I'll ask you,
ask you a question.
You know,
with so many colleges becoming these
kind of strident safe places to demand
their own aesthetic,
what is it like doing comedy?
Well,
it hasn't changed that much.
People getting a little got a little bit
more sensitive because they're aware
that other people were more sensitive
without the audiences that come to
nightclubs,
which is primarily where I perform with,
I do a theater.
Those people were there to see
May.
So that's,
they're usually pretty loose,
pretty fun.
But if you're in a nightclub,
they're there to see,
especially the comedy store.
I'm one of the good things about the
comedy store is there's literally two
dozen people on the lineup then,
not necessarily just here at cu.
They're there to see Anthony Jessel neck
and Chris delea and all these other
comedians that are also there as well.
So you get a,
a much broader comedy audience,
but their nightclub audiences,
they have a few drinks in them.
Maybe they smoked a little pot before
they got there.
Those people there to have a good time.
Colleges are a nightmare now.
It's a nightmare because it's
recreational outrage.
It's,
it's kids who have been under the
control of their parents for most of
their life and haven't had their own
sovereignty and identity and now they're
free and they are very quick to uh,
be outraged.
They,
they want a porn out there.
Moral superiority.
There wasn't virtue signal and every
opportunity they want to shut down
anything to think is air quotes
problematic.
They don't want things to go on a bad
when they think for some reason that
comedy should be uplifting and it should
only punch up.
Like I had this conversation once with a
professor who wrote a book on a comedy
and he said all great comedy punches up,
and I said,
that's bullshit.
I said,
one of the greatest bits of all time is
Sam kinisons bit about starving children
in Africa about watching those
commercials were starving.
Kids are in Africa and you know,
couldn't you please help?
And he goes in,
you know kinnisons like he just want to
grab the guy but hey,
why don't you help them?
You're right fucking there or send
someone like me.
He goes,
send something like me was going to take
these people go,
hey,
we just drove here 5,000 miles with your
food and it occurred to us you wouldn't
be world hunger if you people would live
her the fucking food as he goes.
Can I hear you say that?
That sand,
we got sand in America too.
We just don't live in it,
asshole and he's done.
He goes in,
one of the greatest bits of all time is
literally about
starving babies in Africa.
It's one of the greatest bits of all
time.
And he didn't have anything to say.
He didn't know where to go with it.
I'm like,
don't,
don't say comedy is only about punching
up.
That's crazy talk.
That's what you're doing is you're f
there's,
there's this moral thing that they're
trying to achieve that literally is
completely independent of humor.
It's not what's funny.
It's like there they want to,
they want it to be a multipurpose tool.
Hmm.
They want it to be funny as well as
morally uplifting and great for people
who are discriminated against and
amazing for folks who are marginalized
and uplifting for those who are
disenfranchised.
Well that's not what comedy is.
Comedy is funny.
Those things are wonderful and if you
want to do a spoken word show or poetry
or writing or you know,
a one person play those,
those are great.
But that's not funny.
Comedy is funny.
So it's either funny or it's not funny
and some things are funny that are
fucked up.
You know?
Kennison had a bit about homosexual
necrophilia acts or paying money to
spend a few hours undisturbed with the
freshest male corpses.
And He,
so he had lied down on his stomach and
he goes,
you imagine these people,
they're on the slabs are like well,
went through life and had a good time
and everything and now I guess I'm going
to go and be with Jesus and
Hey,
what the hell is this?
And he's rocking back and forth.
It feels like some guy's got his dick in
my ass.
You mean life keeps fucking with they
ass even after you're dead.
It never ends.
You would close on it cause it was that
he couldn't follow it.
Who was such a powerful bit.
It was about a dead guy getting fucked
in the ass.
There is no further down that you could
punch other than starving babies in
Africa.
You know,
and I'm not sure about it,
this is punching down,
but do you remember the s the routine
that kind of put Whoopi Goldberg on the
map a million years ago about being a
black surfer chick?
No.
Oh,
you know,
she did it on television.
I must've seen it on cable when I was
like 19 years old,
but she talks in valley speak.
Nobody's seen this will be person
before.
She's brand new.
Nobody's ever seen her on television and
she's got this funny name and she's
doing this.
Val speak about being the only black
surfer chick on the beach and she loves
surfing and she loves this one white
surfer guy.
And she finally hooks up with them and
then she realized that she's pregnant
and it's all very funny.
The whole front end,
you're just roaring with laughter and
then she's pregnant and she doesn't know
what to do.
So she gets a rusty wire coat hanger and
she goes into a public bathroom on the
beach and she gives herself a coat
hanger abortion and it spills out there
on the concrete floor and everything's
okay.
And now I'm back on the beach and I'm
just doing fine.
And why don't you come on down and see
me here on the beach?
It's great down here.
It's great.
Holy Shit.
It's a fantastic piece.
And she did it on television and she did
it on tv and it started so light,
like an IRA,
11 novel,
and then I went to such a dark,
horrible place and then it came up with
just this kind of token.
Everything is okay ending every I'm
going to be all right,
don't worry.
This is just something that happened to
do that.
It just leaves you shaken.
And that's the kind of comedy I love.
Yeah,
it goes to the dark or that sentimental
place and it breaks your heart and then
it kind of comes out of it a little bit,
but I were 11 to that so.
Well,
Nora Ephron in her books,
she was so good at doing that.
Uh,
heartburn.
Heartburn is fantastically funny,
but by the end you're just weeping.
The book is so sad,
but these are moments that if you're
going to,
you're going to censor people.
If you're going to self censor,
if you're going to decide the people
can't use certain words,
have you going to decide the certain
scenarios are just too upsetting for
the,
the reader,
the these words are going to,
these moments are going to be harder and
harder to achieve and these are the
moments that we're going to talk about.
Like if you and I,
we were in here,
if we were in a bar somewhere and we're
having a few drinks,
talking about great are great moments.
These are the moments we would bring up.
These are the impactful things that
saying that Sarah Jessica Parker joke in
front of those thousand people and
they're booing and hissing and you were,
you're literally on fire under your skin
and you're beating yourself up
viciously.
Like,
why did I say that?
I'm such a jerk.
I didn't need to say that.
That was just cruel and thoughtless and
yeah,
but if you said that exact same joke and
it killed,
I'd still kind of beat myself up.
Right.
You'd be like,
who is awful?
People that are laughing at this
unfortunate girl.
Do you think that the reason why people
love the transformation thing is because
it almost like if everyone feels like
they have a chance instead of like,
that's exactly what it is.
Yeah.
That you can be,
you don't have to be born with it.
Right.
You have a chance of attaining it.
Yeah.
The unfairness.
The,
that is just the reality of life.
You know,
one of the things that Jordan talks
about all the time is the equality of
outcome.
That the,
the,
this idea of equality of outcome is,
it's absurd.
It's never going to happen.
It's not,
it's not what life is.
Life is not about equality of outcome.
It doesn't happen that way because not
everyone's willing to put the same
effort in and not everyone's given the
same
tools at birth.
And you know,
you've gotta be a little careful too,
or you fall into that Jay gatsby trap
where you get exactly what you wanted
when you were four or 14 years old and
you realize,
oh,
this is not an adult's dream.
This is a dream of a child.
It's one of the things that is
interesting.
Yeah.
About your current situation.
And one of the things that I've read
about your take on it,
I don't know how much you want to go
into this,
but you got ripped off.
I got embezzled,
which is a word I can now spell.
Um,
was it someone you trusted?
It was,
it was,
uh,
the accountant for the agency that
represented my work.
And this is a man who had worked with
for almost 20,
21 years and one of my favorite people
in my professional life.
Fuck.
Oh.
And
what I thought was interesting was your
take on it.
I mean,
the whole thing is horrific and
everyone's worst nightmare.
Uh,
you know,
who,
who trust people with their money.
But what was interesting is you,
you decided that there's some merit to
this.
There's some benefit to this,
that this is going to make you hungry
again.
This is like you have to work now.
And also that,
uh,
that I have been really poor in my life
and it was never my goal to be really
rich.
It was never my goal to have money.
It was my goal to be a writer.
It was my goal to be able to write books
for a living and I can still do that.
You know,
I've been poor.
Poor is not something I'm afraid of.
Uh,
as long as I can write books,
I'll be a happy person.
You had to be rich and to not be
creative.
Like as if you know people.
You sure does.
He go to those parties as rich people
parties and all they have to talk about
is their servants is I hate my maid,
I hate my gardener.
We Ha we have this new person to do
that,
this and they're doing a lousy job and
all they have to talk about in their
lives is their household help.
I hate those parties
or objects or objects.
Yeah.
There was a guy that used to live down
the street from as to call them bling
bling because every conversation that I
would have with them,
it would eventually be like,
uh,
yeah,
look at this new car.
God,
where'd you get that watch?
Or,
you know,
w w what kind of car you drive it and
like we didn't know is what did you do
to the house?
You got a new sank,
you know,
it's got a new TV,
which,
which size did you get?
It was always objects.
It was always things,
you know,
he was just this strange guy that was
just working for things.
Uh,
the same things that everybody else has
working for.
Just a different combination of things.
But it's a game,
you know,
trying to accumulate points in the game,
and because these things are difficult
to achieve,
then they become attractive and then
they become the main focus because it's
hard to get a Bentley.
You got to save up a lot of money to get
a Bentley.
You know,
how much those costs,
which model is that?
Is that the one with the delay?
We'll look at,
you got the perforated leather seats,
that's extra expensive and then this
becomes the main goal.
Yeah.
But so many people fall into that
bizarre trial says such a strange common
trap.
Well,
you know,
but it's the only trap that we kind of
have.
You are not really trained to again go
to that,
uh,
that place of,
of wanting to,
you know,
learn something to wanting to create
something to apprentice yourself,
to somebody who creates the thing that
you dream of creating.
It's much easier to kind of fall into
the readymade trap of these things are
for sale and the people who sell them,
we'll treat you really nice.
You go into their showroom and they will
treat you so nice and you are always
welcomed there and uh,
and you can have a way of kind of
signaling that you've accomplished
something in a very public way.
Yeah.
It's much,
much harder to apprentice yourself and
to sit down and do those 10,000 million
words or to,
you know,
paint those pictures or whatever,
build those brick walls and really
develop the pride of a skill.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the,
the privates Gillen,
the knowledge that your,
your discipline and your focus allows
you to achieve these works at these
things when they're done.
I mean,
what does that feeling of satisfaction?
Like when you touch the back cover of a
book for the first time and it's over.
No,
that's nothing.
That's nothing compared to when you hear
it echoed in the culture and you hear
people pick up the word snowflake and
you hear all these people say,
the first rule of blank is when you
realize that you've kind of dictated the
semantics of the culture for a period
that feels like power.
That is,
uh,
that's glorious.
When you found out that this guy ripped
you off,
we shocked.
Did you have suspicions before this?
I had no,
no,
almost a year before.
So you had an idea for a year and then
it was confirmed.
It was finally what,
what happened,
you know,
a year ago I was supposed to start
receiving some significant payments from
this year's book and they never came
through and they still never came
through.
And every time I requested them,
the publisher said that they'd been
paid.
But the accountant said that there were
technical difficulties with wiring me
the money or he had personal problems in
his life caring for his mother.
And so there was always some reason why
the money never came through.
And finally,
um,
I kind of,
I told my agent I didn't want to do any
more deals until we had this money thing
resolved.
And at that point,
the accountant,
uh,
made a videotaped confession and his
sense of pled guilty,
uh,
and I believe his sentencing is it going
to be in November.
Um,
but according to the district attorney,
they can't seem to find any of the
money.
So the money seems to be gone.
Kamasi's still,
you know,
it's kind of up in the air.
It's a,
initially they said it was 3.5 million
and now they're saying it could be as
much as 25 million.
And this is from not just me,
this is from Mario Puzo,
his estate.
The man that wrote the Godfather,
this is from a lot of different estates.
The agency handled the estate of,
of uh,
Lillian Hellman and Jacquelynne Susanne
and a lot of very big,
big writers.
Uh,
Edward Gorey,
he wrote those creepy,
wonderful cartoon books.
Uh,
a lot of different writers,
a lot of different estates.
Lost money.
So it was this guy doing this from the
jump or does this somewhere along the
line he lost his mind and nobody really
knows.
Yeah.
Wow.
Jamie,
can you hit that pause button while I go
out and take a leak?
Just gone take a leak.
Oh,
thank God.
[inaudible] don't worry about it man.
I know it's rough.
Um,
get used to it though.
What are we anywhere close to?
Three 30.
We know it's,
it's two 30 but we can end anytime you'd
like.
No,
three 30th kind of my uh,
drop dead.
Okay.
Bye.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Uh,
Neil degrasse Tyson's here.
Ladies and gentlemen.
He's waiting.
He got here way early though,
right?
Yeah.
That was the plan.
He has got some work to do before.
Oh,
okay.
He's probably in the tank right now.
I hope.
Student tents,
right?
Yeah.
Can't believe I fucked up that original.
Sorry.
I was trying to look
to see if anyone else,
but man,
I really thought it was attributed to
him,
but that's me.
Oh,
my fucked up brain.
He's intense though.
Kind of creeps me out with the intensity
a little bit.
What do you think about some of these
shifts,
these written like guts?
Yeah.
You know,
choke.
Yeah.
A couple other ones.
What was the one where,
uh,
someone turn into a Werewolf on an
airplane?
I think that was from his,
uh,
collection of horror stories.
The one,
the alien on the cover.
The,
the process though,
it's like survivor.
He's so perfectly designed for being a
writer,
you know,
like this,
one of the more fascinating things about
this podcast is getting to pick the
brain of someone like him and however,
when would you ever have two plus hours
to sit down with a guy like that and
just find out how he thinks about shit?
Like,
fuck,
I mean,
who is it?
You know how he,
he's never going to let you in like
that.
This is one of the weirder things about
podcasts is that for three hours,
whatever the time is,
the phones go away.
You're,
you're wearing headsets,
which I try to encourage people to wear
it now because for awhile I was like,
yeah,
do whatever you want.
But there's something about the headset
that locks you in.
Your voice is exactly the same level of
sound as my voices.
Cause there it's all coming through the
headsets so it's all combined.
So you're much more aware of talking
over each other and shit like that.
But you're also much more aware.
There's nothing else going on that the
sound of your voices,
it's,
it's by isolating,
by putting the headset on and or
eliminating the outside noise,
you would never be able to,
you'd never be able to have a
conversation with a guy like that.
Like that's gotten this deep into the
game.
Just the,
that's what I was going to hit.
The depth,
the depth of everything.
Yes.
Background in journalism is probably
where that's coming from.
But his appreciation for darkness too.
Yeah.
Like his appreciation for that story of
the little girl jerk and the GRANDPA.
Fuck Dude.
It's a always back gotta stop talking
Shit about them.
Feel better.
Some of this podcast makes people p
tricky on his coffee.
That's it too.
I've developed a superhuman bladder
occasionally though.
I have to get up occasionally.
Um,
so back to this dude ripping you off,
this guy who is your friend.
Um,
so they don't know where the fuck the
money is and now they don't and he's not
talking,
you know,
uh,
I guess he hasn't really talked about
where the money has gone.
At first they thought there was some
dummy corporations and they could
recover the money.
So we were all looking for a big payday,
but now the DA says they cannot the
money
and he doesn't want to talk.
Uh,
or he's saying the money is spent.
I'm not sure.
Don't you want to torture him?
No,
I don't.
Don't you want someone to torture him?
No,
but it's so sweet.
It's so sweet because I've had readers,
readers offer the torture him to kill
him and they say they'll do it free of
charge.
So apparently these are people who kind
of do it for a living.
Yeah.
So damn,
I need to make a list.
Okay.
Like me to get some free killings.
It's going to have to be some people I
really don't like,
but you want the money first.
You don't want to just kill some money,
want to make sure you get that money
first.
Otherwise it's sitting in coffee cans
buried in the Nevada desert.
You know,
I really,
between you and me,
I really don't care.
Really.
No.
You know,
I'm,
I really am.
Seriously not somebody,
it would've given me a little more
wiggle room.
I wouldn't be writing so frantically on
the next book,
I could maybe take a little time off and
I don't know,
relax.
But you know,
this is what I do.
And so what the hell?
Yeah.
You have your health,
you have a million ideas,
great ideas,
a great profession that you love.
You're involved in it right now.
Currently I'm,
we're in the process,
all these projects and so,
you know,
I haven't really lost any of the things
that I really love.
You know,
my dad is dead,
my mother's dead.
And I think after your parents are dead,
there's not a lot that can hurt you that
much except,
you know,
of course the death of a child.
And so,
you know,
you're kind of,
uh,
bulletproof after those things.
Well,
the real issue that happens with
successful people is they lose their
hunger,
right?
They lose that.
It's,
it's a death sentence for comedians.
One of the things that happens with
comedians is the early specials tend to
be really good,
and then the later specials tend to be
really bad.
And it's because these people are now
super wealthy and coddled and there's no
danger in their life and there's no,
no real risk or challenges and there's
no growing or learning.
Everything is just like performing to
people that adore you.
Another aspect,
and I talk about this more and more with
writers,
I know,
is it when you're starting out,
you've got a lot of downtime,
a lot of daydreaming,
daydreaming time,
a lot of slack on structured time,
but the more successful you become,
the more your time is really scheduled
and you just don't have those.
I'm really bored times when you tend to
come up with fantastic ideas,
and so in a way,
being somewhat poor again gives me
those,
does really slack times when the ideas
occur.
That makes a lot of sense.
Yeah.
Um,
again to bring back to Comedians,
Comedians,
uh,
they'll,
they get movie careers and it's another
death sentence for their comedy.
They start doing movies,
they're on sets all day,
they're constantly working and then you
don't have enough time to concentrate on
your standup and you have zero fuck
around time cause you're just doing
things all day.
You lose that.
This is weird namedrop be Brad Pitt
advice.
Brad Pitt told me,
Brad Pitt said that success is actually
one of the failure is actually one of
the best things that can happen because
only failure gives you that kind of
alone isolation,
downtime when you can really reinvent
yourself in a significant way and create
something remarkable again,
that ongoing success becomes kind of a,
uh,
mediocrity.
You really need to fail to fall out of
the limelight long enough to produce
something really strong again.
Totally makes sense.
One of the best things that can happen
to a comedian is bombing when you bomb.
That feeling is so bad.
I was describing as like sucking a
thousand Dick's in front of your mother.
But the problem is the differences that
there's probably someone out there who
would enjoy suck a thousand Dick's in
front of their mother,
but nobody enjoys bombing.
So it's probably worse than that.
But that feeling,
whatever it is reignites your
appreciation for people's attention span
your appreciation for tightening up your
delivery,
your concepts,
figuring out a better way to get them
through.
You never want to experience that again.
And some of the greatest moments in my
own personal journey of standup have
come from eating shit.
That's where they come from.
You've got each,
I mean it's great to do well,
wonderful feels great.
But those eating shit ones,
those are the ones that get you to the
notebook.
Again,
those are the ones that reinvigorate
you.
Have you spending hours and hours in
your hotel room going over sheets of
paper and checking out idea,
making sure these concepts connect
together in some sort of a meaningful
way and figuring out what tightened
things.
Cut out the fat.
When you're in this situation right now
and you're frantically writing now and,
and,
and you know,
and sort of forced into this,
uh,
element of creativity,
this like,
you're,
you're forced to be hungry again.
I mean,
I wouldn't wish it on you,
but in a way,
do you feel like it's kind of a gift?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You in a way,
you have to accept ultimately that
everything is a gift because it's always
about what they call cognitive
reframing,
cognitive reframing,
whatever happens,
you reframe it in such a way that you
recognize the value of it.
Um,
and so yeah,
regardless of what happens,
you know,
before my father got murdered,
he had been asking me for an
introduction to what Nolan,
a writer in 1998 and I kept on thinking,
I am not going to introduce my father to
one a writer because I know he's going
to hit on her.
And I wouldn't just going to be
mortified to have dad hitting on Winona
on a rider.
And he'd always talk about how pretty
she was.
Any chance I can meet her and,
and,
and to tell the truth,
when I got the word that my father had
been murdered by white supremacists to
the mountains of Idaho.
Okay.
One of my first thoughts was I'm off the
hook without Wynona rider thing.
Okay.
And that's cognitive reframing.
And you had to do it all the time.
That's glass half full right there.
How long my father,
but you know,
nobody,
none,
none of our relationships are completely
perfect all the time.
Right.
It's no way around it.
Yeah.
Well that's again,
the great thing about unchained writing
is that you can express those ideas and
that would,
that would be my main concern about any
sort of,
uh,
a workshop or support group or any,
any,
any sort of group of like minded peers
that wouldn't understand that and that
would want you to limit your language.
I just don't,
it just doesn't compute.
Yeah.
And in the platonic world,
yeah,
everybody should kind of get it.
But unless you're ruffling feathers,
even within workshop,
you're not going far enough.
You know,
I loved riding that line in Fight Club,
uh,
where tyler and Marla have sex for the
first time.
And then the most romantic thing that,
that Marla can say is,
I want to have your baby.
So what is the inverse?
So of course Marla turns to him and she
says,
I hope I got pregnant because I really
want to have your abortion.
And that's the line that the movie
studio went around and around.
And even Brad Pitt said,
you know,
my mom's going to see this movie.
I don't want her to see this line.
And they shot that scene with so many
different substitute lines.
And then finally fincher wrote the line
and Helena Bonham Carter says,
I haven't been fuck like that since
grade school.
And at that point,
20th Century Fox said,
can we switch it back to the abortion?
And so unless you're always kind of
pushing to kind of,
you know,
until you get some push back,
you don't feel like you're pushing hard
enough.
And so push back is not a bad thing.
It's just kind of a,
it's proof that you're doing your job.
Does it trend that's happening.
Putting
down though this,
this,
that,
this pushback is coming far quicker than
it ever has before,
is that there's a trend now to,
to limit language and limit creativity
and just limit the subject matter,
trigger warnings and stop people from,
you know,
it stopped people from experiencing
things that might be disturbing.
And I could see both sides of that
because on one hand we've got a
generation that has been exposed to so
much sensationalistic stuff in order to
attain their attention.
They've really been overloaded with the
most extreme versions of everything in
order to get there,
their ticket money or whatever,
they've really been pounded by so much
stimuli.
I could see them kind of really pulling
back and wanting to be monastic for the
rest of their lives.
And on the other hand,
I see them as being a,
as wanting to sort of counter dominate
in order to just create room enough in
the world for their statement.
You know,
they're,
they're moving into a world that's
already so occupied by attention getters
that if they can shut some down,
there might be room for their own
expression.
So I kinda see benefit on both sides and
in a way to there they're dominating
their teachers,
which is good because it's this in a way
of exploring your own power and,
and figuring out what you can do in the
world and that you can have a effect.
You can have agency.
So I don't think it's a totally bad
thing.
That's interesting.
The,
the,
the idea that damn dominating their
teachers is in some way good.
Having the,
well,
it certainly gives you confidence and
lets you understand that you can affect
change even if it's meaningless.
Changed you.
Did you pay attention to what happened
in Evergreen state?
In,
in Washington?
Yeah.
Did you see when there's a,
for people don't know the story.
It's a,
the Bret Weinstein story where the
students decided that there was going to
be a day of absence.
Traditionally it had been where people
of color stayed home just so that people
could recognize the important part that
they play in the culture and society.
But then they had ramped it up and
decided white people are going to have
to stay home now.
And he was like,
that's racist.
And the whole thing went crazy and went
haywire.
And the,
the schools basically fallen apart.
Um,
but there was a scene that was filmed
where the president of the university
was in,
uh,
the president of college was in this
auditorium and he was addressing these
children and uh,
they told him to stop moving his hands
because it was threatening.
And so he put his hands down,
he put them behind his back and they all
started laughing.
And I was like,
wow,
this dumb fuck like this,
this,
this guy's running this university.
And he let them tell him not to move his
hands.
Gesturing is you speaking.
And he's like,
what are the ones,
one of the most nonthreatening Beta
people on the planet?
And this guy is just giving,
just wants to keep his job and try to
silence this mob,
this angry horde of,
you know,
fucking kids.
They're kids.
But when he and puts his hands down,
I probably watched it 10 times.
They all start laughing,
you know,
and just,
I think it just demonstrates how
desperately they want a stronger leader.
Yeah.
They don't want,
they don't respect their,
didn't want to learn from somebody who
is a college professor and has never
really attained anything in the world.
They just don't want to become another
cog in that same kind of,
you know,
we'll,
they want to learn from somebody the
respect and whose attainments the they
respect whose achievements they respect
where that's probably right.
Part of the issue of universities,
right?
Is it these professors are so terrified
of the reactions of the students,
which is not the place you're supposed
to be with a mentor student
relationship.
It's not supposed to be that way.
It's not supposed to be.
The mentor desperately needs the student
in.
Now you see that sometimes in private
schools with rich kids,
they treat their teachers like shit.
And the teachers have to bite their
tongue and cause they,
they have to.
And now this is not,
it's not,
not,
it's not the normal dynamic that exists
with the older wise person and the young
person who's trying to learn from this
person that deeply respects not that
dynamic at all.
It's this old person who's weak and
wants to keep their job and is willing
to tailor their own thoughts and ideas
to this irrational mob of social justice
warriors.
And that's what we're seeing on campuses
now.
You know,
professors calling for censorship and,
and,
and uh,
to stop freedom of expression.
You know,
when I was in college,
my favorite professor,
Roy Halverson,
he was the John Houseman of the
journalism school.
He was this old gray eminence and
nothing made him happy.
You could never please this,
this,
uh,
this John houseman paper chase guy.
Nothing was good enough and,
uh,
nothing would make him smile.
And I worked my ass off to make him
happy.
And I finally got an a in one of his
courses,
but he is about the only professor I
remember out of my entire four years.
It was this man that just didn't take
shit from anybody.
Yeah.
This the dynamic of the kid being in
control.
It's not good for the kid either.
It's not good for any.
When they get out of school,
they're going to be baffled and they're
gonna look for that power in other
places,
that power that they enjoyed in the
universities.
And you're seeing that spill off.
You seen that spill out into,
you know,
social media and different forms of
activism when people trying to re
achieve that power that they had and
sort of forcing people to their will.
And in a way it's kind of a farm camp
because a few of those people will
achieve that power and they will be able
to kind of leverage that power to
something more,
something
larger.
And those will be the,
the,
the next generation of leaders that
emerge.
So this isn't a way a laboratory where
we're leaders are taking form and the
rest of them we'll just kind of filter
down into whatever jobs,
whatever careers.
But there will always have their kind of
glory days when they say to remember
that time we shut down the ROTC
building.
Um,
and that will seem like a,
a big glorious past to them.
But that will be enough.
What's causing all this,
the exam,
if you thought about that,
like why,
why is this ramping up?
Cause it seems like it is.
Hmm.
You know,
on one level it is a disillusionment
with the,
uh,
the goals of the baby boomers.
But so many people have seen their,
their parents achieve what they thought
was going to make them happy with the
houses and the trips and the,
the careers and the possessions and the
wives and the second wives and,
and the step siblings.
And they're seeing their parents get
everything that they want and still not
be happy.
And so you see a generation that's kind
of floundering thinking,
you know,
they don't know what's going to make
them happy.
I don't know what's going to make me
happy.
And so people were really distrustful of
advertisements.
It tell them what's gonna make them
happy.
And so,
you know,
I think it's just a big,
a struggle,
a big everyone in blind in the dark
right now.
So just,
just a reaction to what they see that's
ineffective.
What did they see this going wrong?
That they're choosing to embrace a
different group of values.
Right?
Well and,
but they don't,
not even sure even that new group of
values kind of dictated to them with a
lot of preexisting language.
And so I don't,
I think ultimately that's not going to
be very fulfilling either.
It's gotta be something that emerges
from a kind of lymphoid laboratory like
burning man,
these kind of fringe things that are
all,
uh,
as Victor Turner would say.
There are all kinds of experiments in
how to be,
uh,
that's what fight club was.
Just this kind of experiment in how
interaction could be structured in a
different way.
And these things take place in these
kind of a playful environments like
burning man,
like cacophony society used to,
to do,
uh,
and they're fun.
And the ones that are the most fun,
we'll,
we'll be the ones that are perpetuated.
Burning man is fun and that is why
burning man has existed for 30 years and
occupy was not fun.
And that's why we had one occupy.
And I know people are going to be pissed
off about that,
but no,
every year burning
man is bigger and it's funner and more
people go there and every year we don't
have another occupy.
Well I don't know if that's a valid
comparison cause occupy was infiltrated
by cops and the FBI and they pretended
to be protestors and sat amongst them
and the whole thing was kind of
misguided in the first place.
Whereas what burning man is is a
complete removal of these people from
society.
I mean they decided to meet and one of
the most hostile climates in the world.
And there's something about that,
the recognition that you're out there in
the desert with a fucking mask over your
face and you're dancing with dirty
underwear on and then all these people
are doing it together and then half of
them are fucked out of their mind on
drugs and you're not against something,
you're not protesting something.
You're there to create,
celebrate,
contribute something.
Uh,
yeah.
In the protests also at occupy,
a lot of them were misinformed and they
didn't really understand the process
they're protesting against.
There's a very funny,
um,
famous video with Peter Schiff,
who's been on this podcast before as a
financial wizard who,
uh,
was set up shop there with a $5,000 suit
on.
And he basically said,
I am the 1%,
you know,
ask me questions.
And he interviewed these kids who they
would tell him what's wrong with the
world and the,
the,
you know,
the imbalance of finances and financial
inequity.
And they just didn't understand what
they were upset about.
And he would explain to them how
capitalism actually works and how he's
employing all these people.
And the reason why he makes so much
money,
cause he employs so many people.
And if he wasn't doing this,
these people would be out of work.
You understand that I'm creating
something and you can create something
to,
you can create a business and you can,
if you work hard and you know,
and he's going over these and you could
see that what they're fighting against
is almost like a concept.
They're fighting against this I idea of
of this evil tyranny that's controlling
their fate where they really don't
understand it though.
That's,
that's what occupy was in my opinion.
It was like they knew something was
wrong.
It was almost to me like white blood
cells surrounding an infection,
like there's something fucked up here.
Let's just surround this thing and
figure it out,
and then the swelling and pus and that's
really what it was.
It's like there's a real recognition
that is a gigantic problem with the
financial institutions.
The gigantic problem with the,
the whole reason why the economy
collapsed and the bailouts and these
fucking creeps are getting all these
bonuses,
even though the the,
their companies failed and the tax
dollars had a rescue them.
There was a recognition that there was
something wrong but not a deep
understanding of what the system was
that they were actually protesting.
There was too much of that burning man
doesn't have any of that burning man is
obviously society's fucked.
There's no arguments that it's not even
if it's better than it's ever been
before,
which it probably is,
you know,
if you want to listen to pinker or a lot
of other people that will argue that
it's better and it's progressing into
this better and better path and I think
that's probably right.
Ultimately it's still fucked and burning
man offers this alternative,
like this unique society of free
expression and free love and all these
people having a good time together,
exploring alternate states of
consciousness.
Well Victor Turner who talked about
these lumoid events,
it would say things like burning man.
They also provide an outlet for people
to self select to leave the culture.
They are,
they're killed.
You know,
people who just don't fit in,
they die or they express themselves so
much that they can go back to the
ordinary postal carrier life that they
had before.
Because so many cultures have something
like a Samba,
a festival where you go crazy for a week
and then you go back to your normal life
waiting tables.
So they are in a way an event that kind
of keeps the status quo in place.
But they do create these kind of,
if not aesthetic movements,
they are the dairy,
our laboratory for sort of coming up
with some new form of being together,
some new social structure,
new symbols and uh,
you know,
new narrative.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a fascinating thing for me because
I feel it's trickled off into regular
life and a lot of ways now I know way
more people that are microdosing a
silicide been on a daily basis.
People were more access,
especially now that marijuana's legal
people are way more accepting of people
getting high of people just choosing to
sort of look at the world in a different
way and actively seek these different
states of consciousness.
It's way more common.
It's way more discussed and that's kind
of the way it's supposed to be is that
these things start in the experiments
and the ones that are most successful
become institutions.
Uh,
and in the new ones start,
oh,
but we need know these are the
laboratories.
Portland kind of used to be that way.
Portland was such a laboratory,
incubator city,
but uh,
the cost of living is,
is killing that very quickly.
It's become really trendy.
It's like,
it's a,
it's a hip place to live.
It's a hip and it's identified with hip,
you know,
in a way you kind of get your hip card
just by living there.
You don't have to do anything anymore.
It's like New York City's to be like,
you were tough.
Hey,
I'm from New York,
you know,
I can handle it.
Yeah.
I'm hip.
I'm from Portland.
Nope.
Is that where you live?
I live outside of Portland.
I uh,
I live up in the Columbia Gorge.
It's gorgeous up there,
man.
Yeah,
the fucking green.
Do you guys have a neon glowing?
It rains all the time.
Green in Oregon.
That's just,
we don't experience here for more than a
month.
A year.
Yeah.
We got forest fires right now.
So,
Oh,
do you where you are?
Uh,
not so much this year.
They're not so close,
but the air is still much worse than it
is here.
So fucking forest fires are everywhere
right now.
I've been evacuated a couple of times.
It's pretty terrifying stuff.
Do you like at Georgia?
No,
I live here.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Georgia.
Why just say Georgia?
Somebody told you whisper like no one's
listening.
Don't tell her.
Why.
Have a secret friendship with Jim Goad.
Who's one of the few people who makes me
really laugh even though you know most
of the secret anymore.
Most of the world that hates Jim Code.
Why do they hate gym goad?
Um,
because he writes these very
transgressive in your face pieces.
But when he writes about his brother,
he kills me is some of the most,
uh,
touching stuff I've ever read in my life
about his brother's death.
Um,
so,
you know,
the whole world I think is so fooled and
that they think that Jim gold is a bad
person.
And they think that maybe I'm a good
person when it's just exactly the
opposite of how are you a bad person?
Oh,
let's not even go down that road.
I already told on Cheryl strayed killing
that bird.
Come on.
Do I got to do more?
That's not being a bad person.
That's a person who is appreciative of a
dark moment.
That doesn't make you a bad person.
No,
I'm a bad person.
Are you really?
Give me an example.
You know,
and this is awkward,
but this is another one of those
cognitive
reframing honesty things,
is I took care of my mother while she
was dying of lung cancer,
and even while I was taking care of her
and she was lapsing in and out of
consciousness in her home,
there was a little part of me that felt
is glee that thought I will never have
to worry about mom again.
I will never have to worry about whether
mom is offended by my work.
I will never have to worry about mom
falling down the stairs and breaking her
leg.
That this enormous concern in my life
will be resolved.
Uh,
and it's going to be at the cost of
losing someone I love,
you know,
so much.
But the benefit is that this huge burden
of responsibility is going to be lifted.
And so there was this kind of secret
glee thinking,
you know,
I'm going to,
I'm going to have some freedom here that
I never imagined.
MMM.
Yeah.
Nora Ephron touches on that in her work
when she talks about her mother's death.
And I think it's just a,
it's an,
it's an honest thing,
but it's not a thing that makes you look
very good.
I don't think that makes you a bad
person.
I think that that makes you a person
who's honest about thoughts that are
very uncomfortable.
Yeah.
That,
that is just something that people
think,
I think all the time.
If they're dealing with someone who's
completely incapacitated and they have
to care for them 24,
seven,
but they don't express it,
it's just,
it's just a reality of the burden of
someone who's really sick or really
dying.
Is it?
There's,
there's no getting around it.
I don't think it's about,
that's not a good example.
I need to,
I need an example of why you are a bad
person.
Maybe you just really self critical and
aware of things that other people could
take out of context of the,
the,
the totality of your life.
And just use it as an example.
Put it in quotes and using it as an
example of you being a bad person.
You know,
another thing is I really,
really conflicted about the nature of my
creativity.
Yeah.
This idea that in journalism school
they,
they call the theory seduce and betray
that when you go into an interview
situation,
your goal is to gain the trust of that
person and to get them to reveal
something very intimate that you are
going to betray by revealing to the
public.
So,
okay,
you're just basically going in there to,
to charm them and then to hurt them.
And uh,
and so much of my creative process is
that way because,
uh,
for example,
the guts story [inaudible] the,
the story in which the guy puts the
carrot up his blood,
that was my best friend at the time in
like late twenties and he got
fantastically drunk.
And he told me that carrot story and I
honestly believe he had never told
anybody the carrot story.
And I,
I kept that story in my mind for you
know,
10 15 almost probably 20 years until I
found a way to put it with three similar
stories and make a larger piece out of
it.
And the first time I read that story,
I hadn't seen him in maybe a couple of
years.
This friend and I look across this big
auditorium and there he is and I'm
telling his carrot story in front of
hundreds and hundreds of people and the
look on his face,
he's just stricken
and he hasn't talked to me sad.
And this is why even even David,
did you use his name?
No.
Then fuck him.
But what's wrong with that?
Do people still feel betrayed and get
over it?
You need to hang out with more
comedians.
Infuse a comic.
You'd be laughing.
Well,
you know,
David [inaudible]
has told me,
he said his family is very reluctant to
share their lives with them anymore
because he's kind of made them
involuntary public figures and they have
to deal with the fallout from these
stories about them.
And really only his brother and his
sister amy have kind of been able to
spin this in a good way,
but it alienates a lot of people.
Oh,
for sure.
Well,
especially if you use their actual,
yeah.
Name or people know the origin of the
actual story.
Yeah,
yeah.
But that's,
you're not a bad person,
sorry.
Sorry to break it to you think you're a
bad person.
Those are only examples.
Yeah.
You're not convinced.
No,
no.
I'm just not revealing the worst stuff
that of course,
think that you have to have some sort of
embracing of these dark thoughts to
create the way you create.
I mean,
you're creating these characters that go
down some horrible roads,
both mentally and in reality,
in,
in your work and it's amazing stuff.
But to cultivate that,
don't you think?
You have to be kind of in touch with
those thoughts of your own to kind of in
touch with this?
You know,
this thing where you're watching your
mom dying you,
you are going to be relieved of a burden
and you don't want to tell anybody that
you're kind of looking forward to that a
little bit.
Even though you love your mom dearly,
this,
that,
that's a natural thing that people don't
want to discuss but absolutely exists.
It's the elephant in the room.
And,
and that's kind of like,
yeah,
how comedy works or anything where
you're stating this unstated thing.
You're creating this enormous relief.
Uh,
uh,
my classic example when I teach,
I asked my students,
I say,
so,
so what do you call a black man that
flies a plane?
Okay,
a pilot.
You fucking racist.
You're creating this tension,
right?
Hey,
don't want you to say what they think
you're going to say.
They don't want to hate you.
They like you,
right?
And they don't want you to say something
hateful and awful.
Yeah.
And then you turn it around,
he put it on them.
Um,
and so in a way,
you know,
I always think that's the,
the soul of comedy is to create this,
this tension that you relieve as quickly
as possible.
And the relief occurs as laughter.
I was having dinner
with a,
a good friend of mine,
his wife and a buddy of mine and my
friend's friend and his wife and fun
time the whole night.
Everybody's laughing and joking and,
or have a dinner and having a couple of
drinks and joking around talking about
things.
And I forget
what led to him saying this,
but we were talking about,
oh,
just unfortunate scenarios and you know,
people that just,
their life is not going the way they'd
like it to go.
And things going back and out of nowhere
the guy goes,
well,
that's like this.
My daughter has a,
she had a baby with a black man
and we're,
we're both like looking at him like,
where's this going?
And then he goes and uh,
you know,
I just think it's incredibly selfish to
bring that kid into the world.
And this kid doesn't have an identity.
They're not black and the not white and
they don't,
they're,
they're not going to have an identity.
They're not going to have a group to
belong to.
And my friends,
jaws dropped.
My,
I didn't know the guy had spent on that
night and my drop and I looked at my
other friend who was with me who didn't
know any of these other people.
And everyone's like,
what the fuck?
And then a couple of us get up and go to
the bathroom.
And I turned to my friend Andrew and I
said,
let's get the fuck out of here.
And we just laughed.
And I texted my friend,
I go,
too much racism had to go.
And we just left.
And uh,
but it was so weird.
It's like this guy was holding into this
and he's like,
you know what?
I can trust these people.
It's some racist shit.
I can trust them.
And it didn't work.
And he knew it didn't work.
He knew it went over the world like a
lead balloon.
He knew it.
He could feel it because everybody was
like,
what?
Like,
wait a minute,
your daughter's in love with a man who's
black,
they have a child together and you think
it's incredibly selfish to bring their
kid in the world.
Like what the fuck?
I wish I could remember what the fuck we
were talking about before then.
But what we're talking about before
then,
it was like drug addicts or people fuck
up or you know,
people were directed to gambling or
something and the people whose lives
were in chaos and then he brings up his
daughter having a baby with a,
a guy who was the wrong amount of
melanin skin,
whose ancestors came from the wrong part
of the world for him.
It was weird,
man.
It was,
we,
it was weird also to see him recognize.
I did funny,
you know,
you throw out a story,
I throw out a story.
Uh,
I had a hired car from Philadelphia to
New York once on tour.
And,
uh,
as we were going past liberty hall in
Philadelphia,
this,
this great guy over the philly accent
driving the car,
he points at Liberty Hall and he says,
that building has stood for,
you know,
300 years.
I bet you can't tell me why.
And I just looked.
And I said,
because the bricks are late in Flemish
bond.
I think that's probably it with uh,
the,
the brick bricks are offset in such a
way that they bond in the center.
It's called Flemish bond.
And the guys so silent,
nobody's ever answered the question.
And his father was a bricklayer and he
was so proud.
And he goes,
you're right.
Nobody's ever said Flemish bond.
That's why it's still stands.
And we were best friends and just
talking like crazy all the way into
Manhattan.
We get into Manhattan,
there's two guys walking down the
street.
The Guy Goes,
oh Christ,
I hate coming to New York.
Ah,
the fags.
And I said,
well,
you know,
I'm married to a man and Faggot is
pretty much my middle name now.
Poor guy had to do this whole re
juggling of everything that the guy who
knew Flemish bond was also one of them.
Oh.
And it was one of those wonderful,
kind of icky but necessary moments.
And I know they're horrible,
but you know,
things are better afterwards.
You must have loved that moment though.
You know,
it was a horrible moment because I felt
like I was throwing away any kind of
chatty conversational relationship I had
with this guy.
You seem like just the salt of the
earth.
Great,
funny guy.
And it was just kind of going out on a
limb and saying,
okay,
you know,
he's going to hate my guts after this.
Oh,
when I was a little kid,
we lived in San Francisco from age seven
to 11,
and then moved to Florida,
which is the polar opposite of San
Francisco.
And,
uh,
I,
I really,
I don't know if I'd ever heard someone
use the word faggot before,
but I'd never seen a,
an adult upset about gay people before
him.
And then,
um,
my friend Candy Candido was his name.
Uh,
his dad was Cuban,
they were Cuban.
And,
uh,
his dad slams a newspaper on the,
on the table.
I was 11.
And he's like,
can't believe they're letting these fags
getting married.
He was just so angry and I remember
stopping and thinking like,
here,
here's a man.
This guy is a man.
He's a grown man.
Like he's a grownup,
but yet he's,
he's got this infant idea of what a
person should be like.
They got to fall into this category,
that category.
He's got it locked into his head.
He's a fucking baby,
but he's a man and he's my friend's Dad.
This guy sucks.
This guy made it to 35 years old or
whatever the fuck he was.
And this is his,
this is his operating system that he's
using to navigate its way through life.
I remember it being an important moment
for me because I realize like just
because someone is older doesn't mean
they learned anything,
you know,
and that people are capable of success
in life.
You know,
you could become married,
you can have children,
you get a house,
you get good job,
you drive a the hold that you got it
all.
If you've got a checkbook,
you got fucking you,
you're,
you're operating,
it's moving,
you're successful,
it's happening.
And yet you still have these
stupid ideas.
But I think that the,
the,
uh,
there's a benefit to the expression of
the stupid idea,
not that they can be challenged,
but that at least when we're aware that
it's there.
Yeah.
And that,
you know,
we know that this thing is not just kind
of festering and that there's a way of
kind of not fixing this person,
but at least we know where they're
coming from.
Yeah.
I know it.
Ah,
another shooting myself in the career
foot thing.
I don't think you've done it once the
whole show.
Okay.
Here it goes.
I read the daily stormer.
Andrew Anglin cracks me up.
Who is that?
He is the completely transgressive guy
who really loves fight club.
Oh,
writes for the daily stormer.
I think he is the daily stormer and he
writes the most atrocious,
insensitive,
uh,
brutal things,
but they are there so shocking and so
transgressive that,
uh,
that sometimes I laugh just out of the
shock,
you know,
uh,
the old classic joke,
how do you get a nun pregnant?
You fuck her?
You know,
there's a shock value there that,
that just sort of jars me.
It makes me laugh.
Sometimes
that joke would work better if you
hadn't told the black pilot choke first.
Well,
of course the problem is like people
become,
uh,
you know,
you know what's coming.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
but sometimes,
you know,
I,
I want to go into a world where people
are not watching their language so
closely and,
and I see people kind of a vent the
worst of themselves,
right.
And I'm not kind of endorsing it,
but I feel a little less reactive to
abuse.
A scientologist has had this exercise
called bull baiting where they take you
into a room and people surround you and
they call you every horrible thing.
And then they,
they nit pick horror.
Every aspect of your appearance or your
character,
who you are,
and they attack you on every level.
And they do this for long,
long periods of time,
and they do this day after day until you
are completely not reactionary to that
kind of verbal abuse.
You can,
you can put it over there,
you can accept the fact that it's
somebody else's statements,
somebody else's opinion,
observation,
that it's not true and you can be with
it.
And so in a way,
when I go into these sites that are so
patently offensive and in a
deliberately,
you know,
aggressively offensive,
I feel like in a way there are
thickening my skin that,
uh,
I'm not quite a such a delicate little
reactive thing afterwards.
Do you worry about someone looking
through your search results or the far
worse things than that?
Yeah.
You see that in fighting.
Um,
there's certain people that react really
poorly to trash talk and there's certain
people that get excited by it and it
doesn't bother them at all and they
embrace it.
And generally it's people who grew up in
abusive households and horrible
environments.
Then when the trash dark starts coming,
they go,
oh yeah,
oh,
okay,
that what's going to happen?
Fuck you bitch.
And then the,
and then you see them get excited by it
and then you see them like saying,
oh,
okay,
now you've given me more motivation to
fuck you up.
Whereas some people genuinely need to
get dwarfed by this.
You think they get,
they get the pressure of not just being
in conflict,
but some person,
but that person insulting them and
verbal conflict and demeaning them and
mocking them.
It haunts them.
It haunts them and it ruins them and
they can't perform.
They go out and they fight.
They fight terrible.
It happens to a lot of fighters,
guys who were tough,
tough guys.
Something about the,
the verbal conflict and the abuse.
There's an emotional struggle that
they're not prepared for.
They prepared 100% for this physical
struggle,
but there's a certain aspect of someone
literally hating them as a human,
like not thinking of them as a worthy
competitor who they respect,
who they're ready to go to,
battle with.
And we'll shake hands first and
afterwards we'll go have a beer together
after we beat the shit out of each
other.
Now it's like you're,
you're a little pussy,
you're a bitch.
You shine.
It shouldn't even be here.
You're weak.
You're going to fall apart,
man.
You know you're going to fall.
Put your waiting to fall apart.
Just give me a neck.
I'll choke you out.
Make it nice and easy.
And you see guys reacting to that,
these demons inside of them that these,
these are thoughts that do dance around
the back of their brain and every day
they're throwing water on it.
But every day they come back in,
the fucking embers are still smoldering
shit.
And this guy's just pouring gasoline on
that shit and it just takes over the
consciousness.
You see them,
they can't sleep good.
they look exhausted.
You see the day of the fight,
they look nervous.
They look,
they look really worried.
It'll look really worried.
This person's right.
That person is planted these seeds of
doubt that are these invasive species
plants that are choking out all the
trees.
It's wild to see.
It's wild to see how the same words can
have a completely different effect on
different people.
So there you are.
It's a different kind of resistance
training.
Yeah,
no,
there's definitely something to that.
There's definitely something to be
around abusive people to being around.
I mean,
you get accustomed to stuff.
You get you,
people are very,
they're very malleable now you can,
you can get accustom to really shitty
behavior.
I mean,
this is not like,
this is what's got to happen when you're
in war,
you get accustomed to it,
you get accustomed to violence,
you get accustomed to all that.
And one of the more difficult things for
people postwar is coming back into a,
uh,
a kind,
gentle,
boring world.
It's almost like they,
they,
I mean,
that's hurt locker,
right?
They,
they'd appreciate the danger.
They appreciate that.
The thrill of it all is almost more,
more appealing than the absolute lack of
thrill,
the thrill of potential violence and
death and all the horrors that you'd
come into contact with.
It's almost preferable.
Did you read,
uh,
Sebastian younger's tribe?
No.
That's a new one,
right?
Yeah,
it's great book,
but it's about that.
It's about the why,
you know,
being in these intense,
like really dangerous but crackling with
energy environments produce some of the
happiest moments for these people's
lives and that post post war,
like they have an incredibly difficult
job to sort of reintegrating to normal
flats is society.
Yeah,
I could see that.
Totally.
What time is it?
Three 15.
Let's wrap this up,
chuck.
Gotta.
Listen,
man,
I really appreciate you being here.
I really appreciate picking your brain
and,
uh,
I thank you very much man,
and thank you for all your,
all your writing and all your work and
stay fucked up.
Well,
yeah.
All right.
Hey,
thanks for the plane ticket.
My pleasure.
Um,
when can we expect this book when you,
uh,
when you get in,
this is going to be done.
This is this book.
This book is just,
uh,
is,
pages and an o book right now.
This is not for next year.
It's fight club.
Three next year will probably be a big
fat writing book from me.
And this book will won't be until 20,
20.
Yeah,
two years.
Alright.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Okay.